ho detto non snack e bevande
ti ho legato le gambe prego signora
Cos'è quello Benvenuti su Anita Stories
oggi proverò i trucchetti per nascondere
gli snack i dolci popcorn al cinema
senza essere scoperti dal controllore ci
sono Infatti tantissimi trucchetti
YouTube dal canale one two three Go trum
trum Five nightscraft che fanno vedere
come nascondere gli snack al cinema
senza essere scoperti vi sarà anche un
controllore molto cattivo e attento
Quindi dovrò stare molto attenta a non
farmi scoprire ci saranno quattro round
se vinco più di due round avrò vinto la
Challenge Se invece il controllore mi
scopre per più di due round Avrò perso
la Challenge dovete vedere dove nascondo
gli snack sapete benissimo che non posso
tenere gli snack in giro per casa
altrimenti Vitale li mangerebbe tutti
quindi questo è il mio Nascondiglio
segreto guardate
vedete questo guardate
si apre c'è uno scompartimento segreto
in cui nascondo
Guardate un po' pop corn a volontà varie
merendine patatine snack e proverò a
nasconderli senza farmi vedere dal
controllore Ma voi Mi raccomando
lasciate un bel mi piace se questo video
irraggiungibile 20.000 mi piace ci sarà
una seconda parte in cui dovrò
nuovamente trovare a nascondere gli
snack senza farmi scoprire dal
controllore ma provando nuove tecniche e
trucchetti Anzi Consigliatemi pure voi i
vostri trucchetti su come nascondere gli
snack giù nei commenti e se non mi
seguite ancora su Instagram andate a
seguirmi il nome Anita Stories e se
volete Seguitemi anche su Tik Tok ma ora
iniziamo subito con il primo trucchetto
il primo trucchetto utilizzerò questa
una Gloss praticamente la metterò qua
nella pancia così sembrerà che sono
incinta ma in realtà qua dentro ci
saranno un sacco di snack nascosti Spero
che funzioni Proviamo subito e vediamo
Purtroppo però questa cross ha questa
coso qua e così sembra che ho tipo un
ombelico gigantesco cioè Ecco qua
Guardate quanti snack ho messo qua
dentro Ora proviamo a metterlo nella
pancia e speriamo che non cadano Vediamo
se funziona
Ah ah ah okay ragazzi funziona perché
gli snack sono qua dentro e non cadono
L'unico problema è appunto che c'è
questo coso qua e sembra che è un
ombelico gigantesco Guardate ah ah ecco
il controllore non se ne accorga proprio
per questo Oppure provo a toglierlo
questo ombelico vediamo se si toglie
forse si toglie Guardate si sta svitando
uh uh
ho tolto l'ombelico ma ho scritto oltre
solo questa pallina e rimane questo coso
vediamo se si vede Beh dai Si vede un
pochettino ma non troppo Ora provo ad
andare al cinema sperando che il
controllore non se ne accorga
quello laggiù è il controllore lui
controllerà se ho qualche snack nascosto
addosso vediamo se riusciamo a vincere
questo primo turno
[Musica]
interessante questi film
e devo andare al cinema Stop
dove l'ho messo aspetti un momento
Ecco l'ho trovata
Ehi Che c'è Non ti toccano i miei
bambini eh prego signora
Cos'è quello non lo so deve essere
caduto
Non lo so a qualcuno che c'era prima Ok
vado
signora
ok
Sì siamo riusciti per il primo
trucchetto Guardate un po'
tantissimi snack da vedere durante il
film
[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi Prossimo trucchetto in
questa prossimo trucchetto dove
nasconderò gli snack qua nel cappuccio
Spero che non si vedono mettendo il
cappuccio così altrimenti mi dovrò
mettere il cappuccio così in testa ma
forse così si vedono di più quindi
proverò a lasciare gli snack qui nel
cappuccio purtroppo non ce ne saranno
tantissime ma l'importante è riuscire a
intrufolarci senza che il controllore ci
scopro Ok ecco tutti gli snack provo a
metterli nel cappuccio vediamo se ci
riesco Ah sono riuscita ok Devo solo
fare in modo che non si vedano Dai così
non si vedono mi sembrano Voi li vedete
Ho un'idea Ecco così non dovrebbe
accorgersene forse Speriamo
Speriamo che non se ne accorga
biglietti per favore
ecco qua
Grazie
la sala è la numero 4
che cosa ha là dietro mi faccia
controllare per favore
[Musica]
che cosa sta nascondendo signorina
niente Meno male Mi ha chiamato
Signorina io non signora come prima
molto bene
se non sta nascondendo niente allora si
mette il cappuccio per favore
ok
ancora
cosa mi è caduto lì per terra Non lo so
è caduto dal soffitto l'ho visto che
cadeva dal suo cappuccio
tutto sequestrato può entrare a vedere
il film ma senza bevande e senza cibo
sono sequestrati subito
Prego si accomodi Questi rimangono qui
con me
Uffa Vediamo se ne è rimasto qualcuno
No non è rimasto niente Chissà poi lui
cosa ne fa degli snack una volta che li
sequestra
prossimo trucchetto dove nasconderò gli
snack questa volta allora io porterò con
me questo pupazzo facendo finta di
niente dicendo che insomma è il mio
pupazzo che mi fa sempre compagnia
quando vado al cinema ma in realtà è uno
scompartimento segreto sotto questo
pupazzo ta ta ta ta è una zip e qua c'è
una tasca per nascondere qualcosa e noi
ovviamente nasconderemo degli snack non
è molto grande vediamo cosa ci sta
dentro proviamo a mettere un po' di
snack Allora vediamo se ci sta una
coca-cola no non ci sta Uffa abbiamo un
pacco di patatine
Ah ok Forse il pacco di patatine si sta
ma poi non ci sta nient'altro Prova ad
aggiungere questa dolcetto
sì c'è stato cos'altro potrei aggiungere
vado ad aggiungere questa barretta Sì
esplodendo meglio chiuderlo dobbiamo
riuscire a chiuderlo bene altrimenti se
ne accorgerà Ecco fatto l'ho richiuso
con la zip
Speriamo che non se n'è accorta facciamo
finta di niente speriamo di riuscire a
passare con il nostro pupazzo pieno di
snack
Prego favorisca quello che ha lì in mano
No questo è il mio pupazzo
Ah ok
Grazie Facciamo controllare
E come mai è un pupazzo in mano perché
il mio animale da compagnia posso
controllarlo
Non si preoccupi sono non nasconde
niente farò solo una piccola ispezione
tengo pure mi ha attaccato il suo gatto
prego per comodi
ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi ora andiamo a
prendere gli snack un pacco di patatine
una barretta e un altro dolcetto
[Musica]
prossimo nascondiglio
proverò a nascondere gli snack dentro a
questo cappello di Super Mario ho scelto
questo cappello di Super Mario perché è
molto grande qua sopra e c'è molto
spazio quindi dovrei riuscire a farci
stare un bel po' di snack Guardate Ho
anche preso questi mini contenitori di
popcorn Ma quante sono carine
Guardate che carino la mia mini
confezione di popcorn Forse essendo così
piccola non si accorgerà che la sto
nascondendo Secondo voi mmm Devo
smetterla di mangiare devo sbrigarmi
dovevo riempire il nostro cappello
Allora che cosa ci mettiamo dentro
mettiamo Un'estate al limone Sì lo so
che siete quasi tutti in pesca Ecco qua
Ok vediamo un pacco di patatine Mmm una
merendina un altro pacco di patatine
tipo i pop corn ho paura che si
rovesceranno qua dentro ma proviamo a
metterli adesso dobbiamo mettere il
cappello adesso
vediamo
non è molto stabile
No devo togliere il tè altrimenti è
troppo pesante
Uffa devo svuotarlo un po' ok ora è
molto più leggero e non cade Come non
detto ok Così non dovrebbe cadere ma
devo stare molto attenta ai movimenti
che faccio altrimenti cade tutto e il
controllore se ne accorgerà andiamo
[Musica]
che c'è
come posso aiutarla e io veramente
volevo solo un consiglio su Che film
vedere molto bene per interessata a
questo ho visto che lo notava Sì questo
karate dog che cos'è Si tratta di un
cane che dopo essere stato bullizzato da
altri cani decide di prendere delle
lezioni di karate e che si rivolge ad un
anziano maestro per insegnargli l'arte
del carattere Ecco perché Carate Dog e
questo invece Merlino Balboa Merlino
Balboa Questo è un famosissimo film dove
recita dal famosissimo attore Merlino
appunto lui prende delle lezioni di
pugilato diventerà un bravissimo pugile
ma non ti voglio spoilerare addirittura
su questo Ah ok allora procediamo Voglio
vedere karate doghe magari gli altri li
vedrò un altro giorno però andiamo dai
sbrighiamoci vado a prendere il
biglietto lì e poi vengo qui per
l'entrata farò la perquisizione di quel
cappello
Perché Cosa c'è di male nel mio cappello
mi sembra un po' sospetto comunque ha
bisogno del biglietto
cosa che è caduto dentro a terra
niente
Eccolo il mio cappello il mio cappello
quel cibo non è ammesso lei può entrare
ma senza quel cibo che verrà sequestrato
dipende dal cappello
Ah sì ok solo il cappello Prego si
accomodi
e anche questo cibo
e sequestrato tutto per me
Uffa il controllore ha scoperto il mio
nascondiglio degli snack cioè il
cappello e me li ha sequestrati
Guardate che cosa era rimasto qui i mini
pop corn almeno potrò mangiare i mini
pop corn durante il film certo non sono
tanti sono pochi ma meglio di niente Mmm
ho fatto proprio un bel bottino oggi Oh
che bello ora si mangia
Ecco il trucchetto per il primo round ok
Sì non c'è niente ancora voi sarete
pensando ma metterei gli snack nella
tasca No Perché ce ne sarebbero poche e
poi lui controllerebbe le tasche e se ne
accorgerebbe subito quindi lasceremo le
tasche vuote così lui se controllerà le
tasche penserà Ah sono vuoti Allora non
nasconde niente ma andremo a nascondere
gli snack qua
e qua Sperando che non se ne accorga
quindi attaccherò vari snack con lo
scotch qua e con lo scotch qua Merlino
mi sta guardando malissimo e sta
pensando ma che sta facendo
mi sono dimenticata di dirvi se non mi
seguite su Instagram andate a seguirmi
il nome Anita Stories Se volete
Seguitemi anche su Tik Tok il nome Anita
Stories Merlino Che ne pensi Secondo te
riusciremo a vincere la Challenge questa
volta ma come no Merlino non credi in me
mi raccomando devi allearti con me non
con il controllore Bravo bravo che cosa
abbiamo come snack come sempre abbiamo i
pop corn che è lo snack buono per il
cinema e poi andiamo a svuotare questa
busta qua che vedete
Ecco qua gli snack che andremo a
nascondere
sembra il giorno della Befana Quando
apri la casa del fierissima di snack e
poi li mangi tutto il giorno poi ti
senti male devi venire mal di pancia ora
inizierò ad attaccarli qua al tre
Sperando che non cadano devo stare
attenta a non attaccare cose troppo
pesanti Altrimenti potrebbe scoprirmi
Okay Guardate ci sto riuscendo attaccato
queste cose con lo scotch e sembra che
abbia funzionato bene purtroppo posso
attaccare solo cose leggere perché
altrimenti le cose pesanti cadrebbero
Quindi ora vado ad attaccare questo
cioccolatino Qua sembra che funzioni
ragazzi guardate non si vede niente e 3
2 1 3 Ecco qua gli Slime Ecco sì secondo
me riusciremo a vincere questo turno
Secondo voi L'importante è che io sia
molto attenta a non fargli cadere e devo
anche cercare di non
andiamo subito al cinema e vediamo se
riusciamo a superare questo turno
[Musica]
favorisca il biglietto per favore
adesso no
il suo film nella sala 1 Tuttavia
Sì cosa hanno il giubbotto
sento dei rumori strani Ah per caso con
sei cibo bevande no
mi faccio vedere nelle tasche
non ho niente nelle tasche quindi posso
anche andare signorina non mi dica che
sta nascondendo qualcosa Eh come può
vedere qui eh eh C'è scritto qui eh
Niente bevande Ma per quale motivo
indossa un impermeabile non piove mica
all'interno delle sale lo sa eh eh eh eh
non so benissimo che non piove
all'interno del cinema ma io ho freddo e
ho bisogno di
Non c'è bisogno della giacca quindi se
la tolga mi faccia controllare Senti io
sono una persona molto
freddolosa ok Quindi io devo alzare il
rumore ho sentito un rumore di pacco di
patatine questa settimana no
che cosa ho detto mi faccia controllare
colleghi siete pronti Sì ho bisogno del
vostro aiuto qui alzala uno va bene va
bene sto togliendo la giacca
ho visto qualcosa
Le è caduto Mi è caduto di tutto e di
più da quella giacca
per favore già cos'è per strada
posso entrare almeno Sì certo non ha
nient'altro lì no prego
una bella ciao
me la provo ma chi è che me la tengo
mi sta bene
Uffa round fallito la prossima volta
devo provare un metodo migliore Anzi
consigliatemelo voi nei commenti chissà
cosa starà facendo ora con la mia giacca
Sì sì
[Musica]
prossimo turno proverò a nascondere gli
snack
qui in un salvadanaio vi ricordate
l'altra volta li ho nascosti nel pupazzo
e lui non se n'è accorto Quindi questa
volta dentro quel salvadanaio anche se
si dovesse accorgere che c'è qualcosa
dentro al salvadanaio penserà No non
posso romperlo però aprirlo devo per
forza romperlo ma in realtà tu non si
può aprire da qua Ed ecco qua che
infilerò gli snack alla fine del video
dovrete scrivere nei commenti Qual è il
turno che vi ha fatto più ridere che vi
ha divertito di più E se non l'avete
scritto nello scorso video in cui
nascondevo Disney andate dopo questo
video a vederlo e a votare il vostro
turno preferito purtroppo Anche qua ci
staranno cose molto piccole ma meglio di
niente vediamo
questa città Vediamo se le caramelle ci
stanno
e pop corn Pop corna volontà
Merlino sta qua sotto che sta cercando
di prendere qualche popcorn perché
Merlino adora i Popcorn Ecco fatto
Guardate è pieno di popcorn Speriamo che
non se ne accorga ora dobbiamo
richiuderlo con il tappo Ah un rumore un
po' strano ma io farò finta di niente E
certo penserà che è un po' strano che è
una persona si porta il salvadanaio al
cinema mamma Mi inventerò qualcosa
[Musica]
aspetta aspetti ferma Sì cos'è quello
chi quello che hai in mano Ah il
biglietto Grazie
E cos'è che hanno l'altra mano ma in
realtà
così posso scegliere i nuovi film da
vedere nuove uscite sono proprio qui
all'inizio della fila Abbiamo il
tirtanic super Wars Titanic parla di una
grande grandissima nave e dove vede per
protagonisti due bellissimi Giovani nel
loro cane e Ok allora invece super Words
riguarda appunto di un cane e della sua
padroncina che viaggiano in questo mondo
stellare fantastico con le loro spade
laser dovranno difendere il mondo
l'umanità e gli altri universi Ok scelgo
super Words posso andare Ti prego si
accomodi
sono invincibile non mi sfugge niente
Sono troppo bravo Sì sì sono proprio
bravo invincibile infallibile il
migliore nessuno potrà entrare col del
cibo con me
avete visto ragazzi sono riuscita a
distrarlo chiedendogli dei nomi film e
sono riuscita intrufolare il mio
salvadanaio pieno di snack è arrivato
anche carino per mangiare gli snack
vieni
non vi ricordate i mini popcorn
Quale sarà il prossimo trucchetto un
trucchetto che mi avete consigliato voi
nascondere gli snack nella mascherina io
ho queste due vediamo qual è più grande
così conterrà più snack dentro questa ha
i fiori
ricamati Forse è più grande questa
Guardate Ok ragazze in realtà potrei
nascondere gli snack qua nel taschino
della mascherina vediamo guardate C'è
Merlino che è molto curiosa di quello
che sto facendo lui vorrebbe mangiarti
tutto ma Merlino No tu non le puoi
mangiare queste cose bene Sono ben
nascosti non penso che li troverà
vediamo Ora come mi sta la mascherina
sembra che ho un becco secondo voi se ne
accorgerà o no Spero che non se ne
accorgerà proviamo andiamo
[Musica]
ho detto non snack e bevande Ma io non
ho nessuna snack bevande dove potrei
aver messo gli Snack a bevande che
mascherina strana perché
sembra quasi che lei abbia il becco e
perché sono una cicogna No ma che
davanti sono ti posso andare No devo
controllare questa mascherina
sospettati niente di male in questa
Mascherina e sono grande le sta troppo
grande mi faccia controllare ti sembra
come se lei nasconde qualcosa là dentro
sento un rumore strano può venire dalla
sua mascherina Ah per caso un criceto
nascosto là dentro
sembrano delle caramelle ci sono per
caso delle caramelle ci sono per caso
dei cioccolatini ci sono per casa delle
barrette energetiche no c'è un piatto di
pasta
[Musica]
vedi che non c'è niente
cioccolatini e questi sono sequestrati
Uffa posso andare adesso
il mio bottino cresce sempre di più
prego
ha scoperto il mio nascondiglio nella
mascherina nella tasca
Eppure erano nascosti così bene Si
vedeva che la mascherina era troppo
grande cosa starà facendo ora con tutti
i miei snack sequestrati
prossimo trucchetto nasconderò gli snack
Che cosa sono queste forcine per capelli
nasconderò gli snack invece i capelli
Sperando che non se ne accorga magari mi
uscirà tipo una pettinatura strana da
pazza ma l'importante è che non se ne
accorgerà proviamo e in effetti questo
potrebbe sembrare una decorazione del
fermacapelli Guardate
sembra un po' un fiocchetto Vabbè lo
copro così Uhm è un po' strana i capelli
ma Vabbè proviamo ora a mettere queste
caramelle oh ah
Wow
stanno benissimo i capelli così vero
questo pacco di patatine molto grande
non penso di riuscire a nasconderlo ma
proviamoci lo stesso
questo trucchetto È troppo divertente
Guardate che pettinatura Fashion andiamo
e speriamo che non se ne accorga
[Musica]
stop
perquisizione come perquisizione non ho
niente addosso guardi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è caduto qualcosa dai capelli
Sì questo è il mio ferro a capelli
Grazie mi faccia controllare
per l'acconciatura Comunque sia comodi
Grazie
ce l'abbiamo fatta Ora posso togliere i
fermacapelli
patatine
sei proprio cascato alla grande pensava
fossero dei farmaca i capelli due anche
oggi un bel bottino da portare a casa
caramelle snack oro giacca wow wow tutto
per me che bello consigliato voi nei
commenti andrò a nascondere gli snack
una sciarpa Abbiamo qua la sciarpa la
serpe verde e la sciarpa Grifondoro voi
di che casa Siete in questo caso andrò a
usare il Grifondoro Perché si abbina con
la maglietta rossa e andremo ad
attaccare gli snack dentro la sciarpa
poi andrò ad indossare la sciarpa
sperando che il controllo loro non se ne
accorga quando voi se ne accorgerà Ah
ecco qua ho incollato per gli snack
all'interno della sciarpa Ora proviamo
ad indossarla Speriamo che non si
persone che non cadano questi sono
cioccolatini A me da piccola facevano
sempre gli scherzi Ehi ti ho regalato
200 500 euro e poi erano questi anche
voi fanno questo scherzo Ciao
Merlino non solo per te questi
non si vedono Eh ok questa volta è
caduto solo uno due
ta ta ta li ho fissati meglio Questa
volta non dovrebbero cadere Spero non
mettere la
si vede qualcosa se il mio posto Sì
piace coprire meglio Ok ragazzi oggi
snack nascosti nella sciarpa andiamo ora
dal controllore Speriamo che non si è
accordati niente
Ragazzi c'è un problema e continuo a
cadere gli snack
stop
che cosa sta tenendo con la mano
e ho un fortissimo mal di gola quindi è
meglio se mi fai entrare subito
altrimenti la potrei contagiare sarebbe
molto male quindi mettete mi fa entrare
ma io vedo che c'è un sacco di cose lì
intorno al collo No non è vero non e poi
niente Sono mal di gola gliel'ho detto
non mi convince vedo già qualcosa qui
tutti questi snack sequestrati tutti
subito
no round perso
prossimo trucchetto
con una mascherina per gli occhi ma che
cosa ci fai con una mascherina per gli
occhi al cinema dove Dovresti guardare
lo schermo Beh Mi inventerò che al
cinema è l'unico posto in cui riesco a
dormire qua Ah una taschina in cui posso
nascondere gli snack Vediamo quanti ce
ne stanno Eccoci qua con tutti i nostri
snack qua all'interno della mascherina
c'è qualcosa che proverò a rimuovere Mmm
Okay
quanti snack ci staranno qua vediamo
monetine Uh monetine se ne stanno un
sacco Guardate tu
sì ci sta Guardate un po' Ecco qua la
mia mascherina per gli occhi che
nasconde tantissimi snack all'interno
vedete qualcosa MHM Secondo voi Te ne
accorgerà andiamo subito
[Applauso]
[Musica]
così questa è la mia mascherina di
Malefica Sì bravissimo Fai bene Fai bene
ad avere paura e farmi entrare senza
problemi
siamo riusciti ad entrare senza nessuna
perquisizione
vediamo se sono sopravvissuti gli snack
no Merlino non solo per te
l'ovetto e sopravvissuto intero le
caramelle e il cioccolato Sì il
controllore non si è accorto di niente
Ah ah passiamo ora al prossimo turno
prossimo trucchetto per questo
trucchetto userò tanti mini cioccolatini
e farò finta di avere gli addominali qua
e di avere i muscoli mettendo degli
ovetti qua non so
non so se funzionerà Proviamo adesso a
metterli e vediamo com'è l'effetto Wow
ok
Ho sbagliato Cambia maglietta ho
cambiato maglietta così si vede meglio
Sembra nuovamente incinta non che ho gli
addominali Guardate un po' secondo voi
sembra che gli addominali secondo me non
tanto Guardate un po' cosa userò per i
muscoli delle braccia ta da due ovetti
di cioccolato Vediamo se funziona ah ah
ah Ah
wow altro che Braccio di Ferro Il
braccio di cioccolato Uh
super Anita all'attacco Merlino mi sta
guardando malissimo Non ci resta che
andare dal controllore e sperare che non
si accorge dei nostri bimbi i muscoli
andiamo
[Musica]
Salve
Che muscoli Sodi Wow Sì lo so mi sono
allenata tantissimo e sono fortissima
adesso perquisizione
Che cosa c'è che non va Questa volta
sono un po' plasticosi questi muscoli
[Musica]
C'è qualcosa di strano in questo muscolo
è ripieno Ma che succede se
[Musica]
ma l'importante è che sono riuscita ad
entrare senza farmi sequestrare gli
snack
passiamo ora al prossimo
prossimo trucchetto per questo
trucchetto ci aiuterà il nostro
fedelissimo aiutante mascotte della
Stories Family Merlino il cagnolino come
ci aiuterà Merlino con questa felpina
cappottino per cani proveremo a
nascondere qualche snack qui nel
colletto entreremo con Merlino al cinema
e speriamo che il controllore non se ne
accorga Secondo me sarà super divertente
perché anche Merlino dovrà fare finta di
niente Secondo voi ci scoprirà proviamo
Merlino è già pronto
a compiere la sua missione tadà Ecco qua
due snack nascosti Ora andiamo a mettere
la felpina giubbottino su Merlino e
vediamo speriamo che non provi a
mangiare le patatine e i popcorn
Bravo
Merlino Guardate quanto è bello bravo
Merlino Ma sei bellissimo in giallo non
è super carino Merlino giallo Allora gli
snack sono nascosti bene quindi non
penso che il controllore se ne accorgerà
ma anche Merlino dovrà fare il
bravissimo attore vero Merlino Tu mi
raccomando fai finta di niente no
ah ah
Merlino Quanti baci siamo qua con
Merlino che nasconde le cose nella
pettorina e speriamo che il controllore
non ci scopre e lacci che ci sta
guardando in modo strano
Merlino Mi raccomando Stai super attento
al controllore Ok andiamo
come mai lei è qui col cane
Ma come
ti ho riconosciuto no lo guardi meglio
è un cane con coperta addosso non è una
coperta è un bellissimo giubbino giallo
pettorina ma come non ha riconosciuto
guardi qua
guardi e qua e qua e qua e qua e qua qua
interpreta Merlino Balboa può interpreta
il karate Dog qua interpreta un film
pauroso e la star di tutti questi film
li chiedo scusa non avevo riconosciuto
Prego si accomodi signora Star prego
signor cagnolino
[Musica]
Non lo so cosa è successo vieni Merlino
noi dobbiamo andare vieni Bravo bravo
[Applauso]
come ha fatto a cadere lì quel pacco di
patatine che c'era il cane il famoso
Merlino la star Vabbè prendiamolo
Vuol dire che me le mangerò io
no Merlino siamo riusciti ad entrare
Grazie a te e infatti Grazie alla tua
giacchetta pettorina Abbiamo qua i
nostri snack Peccato che hai perso un
sacco di patatine lì per terra Spero che
il controllo non se ne sia accorto
quindi nel video iscrivetevi nei
commenti Qual è il trucchetto che vi è
piaciuto più di tutti e qual è il
momento che vi ha fatto più ridere per
il primo trucchetto utilizzerò un
cerchietto Questo è il mio cerchietto
Grifondoro Andrò ad attaccare degli
snack qua attorno al cerchietto sperando
che il controllore pensi che sono solo
decorazioni del cerchietto e non snack
che sto cercando di intrufolare di
nascosto iniziamo ad attaccarli e
speriamo che non cadano
ah ah ecco qua il mio cerchietto pieno
di snack fanno anche rumore è meglio se
non muovo la testa troppo altrimenti
potrebbero cadere secondo voi se ne
accorgerà il controllore Speriamo di no
andiamo subito
Salve prego Ecco il biglietto posso
andare Sì sì certo può andare ma prima
che cos'è quello uno scanner nascondersi
non si deve preoccupare questo cosa ti
serve dello scanner non capisco Siamo in
un cinema No non in un aeroporto Non si
può portare il cibo e questo è uno
scambio speciale apposta fatto per il
cibo Mmm sembra ci sia qualcosa qua
sopra dove cosa tra i capelli per caso
Uh faccio vedere che cos'è questo
Wow
Ma è bellissimo
sequestrato Uffa posso entrare adesso
una volta rimosse tutte le cose sospette
non c'è più alcun problema e si può
entrare questo invece lo tengo io Wow ma
mi sta proprio bene Ora sì che sono un
controllore alla moda
Merlino abbiamo fallito il primo round
cioè sequestrato il cerchietto troppo il
controllore ha una nuova arma il body
scanner o snack Scan quindi dovremmo
stare molto più attenti con i trucchetti
d'ora in poi Considerando che lui farà
sempre il controllo con lo scanner
Passiamo al prossimo trucchetto e
cerchiamo di non farci scoprire via
prossimo trucchetto per il prossimo
trucchetto mi avete consigliato voi di
mettermi una felpa abbastanza larga con
una tasca e mettere gli snack nella
tasca e dentro alla felpa Speriamo che
funzioni io Ora metterò più snack
possibili dentro la tasca Vediamo quanti
ce ne stanno bene iniziamo a mettere un
bel po' di snack speriamo che ce ne
siano tanti
cioccolatini caramelle altri
cioccolatini vediamo se ci sta un pacco
di patatine Sì devo dire che questa
torta ci stanno un sacco di cose Ok
direi di fermarci qua Altrimenti
potrebbe accorgersene perché è un po'
gonfia questa tasca ma io mi metterò
così e farò finta di niente Ce la faremo
questa volta andiamo
Ciao attenzione obbligatoria Uffa Non
sono permessi snack alcun snack dolci
salati agrodol dolci Agro salati e dolci
e salati salati e dolci solo agrodol
dolci insomma qualsiasi cosa non è
permessa d'accordo
Eh sì è proprio qui nelle tasche svuoto
tutte le tasche
[Musica]
Sì direi che è proprio questo tieni ecco
tutti i miei snack Questi sono tutti i
miei snack Oh deve Svuotare tutte le
tasche E va bene
ha consegnato tutto questa volta
devo andare adesso no prima un'ultima
stazione
Ok prego può andare adesso
questa sera avrò tanti snack per me oh
oh oh no grazie al suo body scanner Anzi
snack scanner è riuscito a scoprire che
nascondevo gli snack Nella tasca della
felpa quindi purtroppo non ha funzionato
però in mente un altro trucchetto che
secondo me potrebbe funzionare anche se
lui usa il body scanner o snack scanner
prossimo trucchetto Speriamo di farcela
per questo trucchetto ho in mente un
piano forse geniale Vi ricordate quando
ho messo una cloche qua nella pancia e
ho fatto finta di essere incinta e l'ho
riempita di snack questa volta farò la
stessa cosa però la metterò qua nella
schiena come se fosse una gobba anche
questo trucchetto me lo avete
consigliato voi Voi siete veramente
super super furbissimi e intelligenti
Continuate pure a consigliarmi i vostri
trucchetti nei commenti perché sono
troppo divertente state pensando perché
non li metti direttamente nel cappuccio
perché ho già provato una volta ma non
ha funzionato Ve lo ricordate Hahaha
Ecco qua Eccolo qui l'ho già riempita di
snack Ora provo a metterli nella schiena
e spero che non cadrà niente e che non
se ne accorgerà con il suo body scanner
sembra che ho la pancia al contrario
guardate C'è anche questo coso qua che è
per afferrare la cloche che sembra tipo
l'ombelico ha un profumo Gigante
secondo voi ci cascherà andiamo e
proviamo
Pronto Sì
No ha sbagliato numero prego
il biglietto ti sbrighi un fortissimo
mal di schiena devo entrare subito
il colpo della befana no com'era della
strega
prego faccio solo una piccola stazione
per vedere che è tutto ok Sì direi che è
tutto ok Prego puoi entrare Davvero Sì
certo ok
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie prego Mi raccomando stia al caldo
incredibile Spero non mi verrà mai il
colpo della strega
siamo riusciti a passare con gli snack
nascosti dentro alla gomma finta non ha
passato il body scanner snack scanner
nella gomma e guardate qua quanti snack
che ho vi faccio vedere subito il
prossimo trucchetto
ultimo trucchetto per questo ultimo
trucchetto mi aiuterà la mascotte della
Sony Family il nostro Fedele aiutante
Merlino dove già io Ah ah ah ah
Grazie per questi vaccini Merlino
Merlino è molto felice
come ci aiuterà Merlino Praticamente
andrò ad incollare gli snack qua nel
guinzaglio poi attaccherò il guinzaglio
Merlino e farò finta che sto portando a
Berlino a fare una passeggiata al cinema
Sì lo so È strano però l'altra volta ci
ha fatto entrare col Merlino Quindi
speriamo che funzioni anche questa volta
speriamo che con il body scanner non si
accorge che ci sono gli snack qua Ma
piacerebbe ispezionare anche il
guinzaglio con il body scanner e
speriamo che non ispezioni Merlino vero
prepariamo ora il guinzaglio e
attacchiamo gli snacks Speriamo che non
cadano
Ecco qua il guinzaglio con gli snack sei
pronto Merlino Ecco qua il guinzaglio
con gli snack Merlino Non vedo l'ora
andiamo Merlino andiamo andiamo
Merlino andiamo
Merlino Eccoci qua che c'è tempo
Ah eccolo Grazie il cane il biglietto
non lo paga Ma glielo devo ripetere è la
star guardi tutte queste locandine
Merlino Stories Ti prego di scusarmi
signor Merlino Stories lo faccio subito
entrare Devo solo fare un piccolo
controllo prego lo scanner anti snack
vediamo
ma ha suonato cosa nasconde qui niente
Che strano
aiuto aiuto
[Musica]
ti ho legato alle gambe
Merlino Ti prego prego Entrate tanto non
ho trovato niente
bravissimo Merlino grazie a Merlino
siamo riusciti intrufolare gli snack
attaccati al guinzaglio
Merlini ho già fatto vincere questo
round pesa tantissimo ho preso qualcosa
di speciale per il primo trucchetto e
penso che il controllore non se ne
accorgerà Spero
che cos'è Secondo voi questo
penso che avete indovinato tantissime
caramelle Ma cosa c'è di strano in
queste caramelle non sono caramelle
normali Ma sono quelle caramelle che si
possono mettere come collana o come
bracciale o come cintura Oh essere
tantissime Oh che carino
Wow mi ricordo sempre che da piccolo lo
volevo tanto ma non li ho mai avute
queste collane che si parmigiano Voi li
avete mai mangiate queste collane con le
caramelle Allora Questa potrebbe essere
un bracciale Non se ne accorgerà mai
Spero Wow ce ne sono davvero
tantissime potrei metterne un sacco
magari per questa volta proviamo solo
con la collana ho paura che altrimenti
con il body scanner se ne accorge Ma se
faremo un altro episodio mi riempirò di
queste collane caramelle Wow Guardate
profuma di vaniglia ora andiamo proviamo
intrufolarci al cinema e speriamo che il
controllore non se ne accorga
stop che c'è biglietto Dominick qua il
biglietto Va molto bene Ora però
facciamo la perquisizione
Ma tanto io non ho portato nessuna snack
siamo sicuri lo scanner sembra non
rivelare alcun cibo Il che è molto
sospetto nel suo caso
niente posso andare direi che può
passare allora solo per questa volta
però eh Ok ciao
[Musica]
Cos'è questo profumo di fragola vaniglia
caramella
ce l'abbiamo fatta sono riuscita a
intrufolare la mia collana caramelle ora
possiamo mangiarle le nostre caramelle
Ma come si staccano da
quarellino
sta pensando Anita impazzita sta
mangiando le collane adesso prossimo
trucchetto cosa userò per il prossimo
trucchetto
Ma che cos'è Che cosa c'è dentro un
peluche un topo un parrucchiere poi ci
siete quasi Merlino sei salito sul
tavolo sta cercando di mangiare le mie
collane caramelle è una parrucca siete
pronti a vedermi con un altro colore di
capelli questo trucchetto me lo avete
consigliato voi avete detto Mettiti una
parrucca e metti gli snack dentro alla
parrucca o sotto alla parrucca non so se
funzionerà proviamo
[Applauso]
sembro tipo granny però giovane Ok
proviamo prima con dei cioccolatini
dentro alla parrucca così sarà
impossibile per il controllare trovarli
proviamo ora a mettere un pacco di
patatine queste possono nasconderlo
sotto i capelli visto che sono
tantissimi
Fanno troppo ridere questi capelli
secondo me ci cascherà andiamo
[Musica]
Ecco il biglietto
per caso ho cambiato colore di capelli
di recente Sì questo è un po' sospetto
che strano è caduto qualcosa
non so signora qualcosa qui
[Applauso]
sono solo i suoi capelli questi è una
parrucca ha qualcosa attaccato
sull'orecchio hahaha
beh va bene tutto sequestrato e anche la
parrucca è sequestrata crede di
ingannare me con questa parrucca chissà
come mi sta mi sta proprio bene questa
parrucca sequestrata Quasi quasi me la
tengo oh oh oh fai il controllore mi ha
sequestrato la parrucca Proviamo con il
prossimo trucchetto prossimo trucchetto
per questo trucchetto Farò finta che
oggi sia il mio compleanno e quindi
niente da metterò il cappellino
Ovviamente nasconderò gli snack qua
dentro nel cappellino cosa possiamo
nascondere qua dentro vediamo un bel po'
di cose cioccolatini
ovetti Guardate Guardate Okay ci sono
riuscita Ragazzi ho messo il cappello
con tutti gli snack dentro Ora devo
andare molto molto piano e evitare che
cadono anche perché se non si rompe
tutto andiamo
[Musica]
non c'è il controllore Meglio così
almeno potrò passare senza nessun
controllo
ci sei Che cosa sta facendo Ma quella è
la mia parrucca No sono i miei capelli
questi sono cresciuti Vabbè posso
entrare Ecco il biglietto
Grazie del biglietto controllo
scherzinsione Come mai indossa quel
cappello Perché il mio compleanno
[Musica]
Tanti auguri a te il biglietto a me
tanti auguri Anita venite con me
no no nessuno snack passa troppo buona
visione Ciao
sono riuscita
ancora tutto qua trucchetto riuscito
passiamo ora al prossimo prossimo
trucchetto per ultimo trucchetto questo
trucchetto è lo stesso lo avete
consigliato voi Voi siete super Furby
super intelligenti Infatti continuate a
consigliare i trucchetti nei commenti in
questo trucchetto semplicemente
attaccherò degli snack quelli più
leggeri Sotto alla gonna Ecco qua il
cioccolatino lo attacco qua sotto Okay
Portate i cioccolatini alla gonna Oh
devo stare attento a non muovermi troppo
altrimenti cadranno e se ne accorgerà
andiamo Uhm
Buonasera salve posso entrare mmm non lo
so nasconde qualcosa attaccato qualsiasi
cibo delle bevande dei cioccolatini
cioccolatini caramelle no mmm
faccio una giravolta
si giri una volta
molto bene
abbiamo qualcosa qui per terra o sbaglio
sequestrato tutto quanto basta molto
bene
tutto mio Uffa Purtroppo questo
trucchetto della gonna non è riuscito ma
il prossimo trucchetto penso che
riuscirà perché è molto divertente ve lo
faccio vedere subito via prossimo
trucchetto vi ricordate in uno degli
scorsi episodi un trucchetto che ha
funzionato molto bene che vi è piaciuto
tantissimo era mettere la croce qua
nella pancia come se fossi incinta e
nascondere tutti gli snack dentro ho
pensato a un altro trucchetto cioè con
un Chupa Chups gigante Lo nasconderò la
stessa nella pancia Sperando che non ci
caschi Anche se questo è un po' più
piccolo rispetto alla cloche e ci sono
già gli snack dentro Speriamo che ci
caschi lo stesso il problema è questo
Cioè il lo stecco del Chupa Chups Come
faccio a nasconderlo Ok andiamo e
speriamo che non si accorga di niente
stop
Sì sta nascondendo qualcosa No non sto
nascondendo niente
eppure lo scanner Individua qualcosa
proprio qui che cos'è Che cos'è prima di
uscire ho mangiato tantissimi snack
dolce e quindi mi sono rimasti un po' in
pancia
[Musica]
va bene ma lo sai che una volta anche a
me è successo la stessa cosa ho mangiato
talmente tanti snack che mi era venuta
una pancia enorme Peccato però che non è
andata più via Hehe Ok però dai che
comodi
siamo riusciti a intrufolare lecca lecca
gigante questo trucchetto è riuscito e
ora qui
Time per voi che siete arrivati fino
alla fine del video Ecco il quiz
composto da tre domande dovete
rispondere alle tre domande giù nei
commenti i quiz saranno sempre relativi
alla serie di video attuale quindi in
questo caso alla serie di video dei
trucchetti degli snack se non li avete
visti tutti andate a vederli tutti dopo
questo video Domanda numero uno dove ha
nascosto gli snack Merlino in questa
serie dei trucchetti degli snack
scrivete nei commenti Domanda numero due
In quale episodio
Ho usato la cloche con gli snack dentro
scrivetelo giù nei commenti Domanda
numero 3 In quale episodio ho attaccato
gli snack al guinzaglio di Merlino
scrivi nei commenti scrivete le vostre
risposte nei commenti e vediamo in
quanti riusciti azzeccare tutte le
risposte Ora vi lascio qua quattro
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione Ciao
[Musica]